y es la primera vez que el canciller
alemán visita a canadá su principal
objetivo será cerrar el acuerdo para
establecer cadenas de suministro de
hidrógeno con el país norteamericano
mientras el temor de que rusia corte por
completo el suministro de gas sigue
latente en alemania canadá no sólo es un
buen socio para alemania sino también un
amigo cercano queremos profundizar aún
más estas relaciones y cooperar
estrechamente
especialmente en las áreas de energía y
protección del clima aunque se espera
que con el acuerdo bilateral se
construya también una planta que usará
energía eólica produciendo combustible
para la exportación lo cierto es que
estos esfuerzos no son una solución para
este invierno ni siquiera para el
próximo mientras tanto el invierno se
acerca hacia europa al norte de alemania
la fábrica del principal productor de
calefacción del país empezó a trabajar
24 horas al día para fabricar las bombas
de calor mientras deja el gas ruso según
su director su demanda de energía es
casi ilimitada tienen cuellos de botella
en el suministro los costos de energía
han aumentado con la guerra en ucrania y
falta personal de cara a la temporada
más fría del año
produciremos alrededor de 80.000 bombas
de calor este año ahora también tenemos
que ser honestos esa cantidad no
coincide con lo que podríamos vender si
tuviéramos una capacidad de entrega
ilimitada las cadenas de suministro
están extremadamente tensas la
disponibilidad de microchips en
particular no es muy buena en este
momento
el gobierno alemán todavía cuestiona si
dejara por completo otra de sus
alternativas la energía nuclear mientras
le quedan pocas opciones ante un posible
cierre total del grifo ruso